sí
hola muchas gracias por estar aquí llevo
siendo emprendedora durante siete años
durante estos siete años mi empresa ha
estado a punto de morir tres veces la
primera vez por un pleito con mi socia
la segunda vez porque en el 2017 en
méxico un tener terremoto tan grande que
el edificio donde estaba mi empresa
colapsó por completo y la tercera por la
pandemia arrasó con la salud del mundo y
muchísimos trabajos principalmente los
emprendimientos esto no es una historia
de tragedia sino que hoy me doy cuenta
que la única cosa que me salvó y mantuvo
a mí ya mi emprendimiento fue que
desarrolle tecnología a mi favor por
otro lado a través de mi emprendimiento
epic win que trabajó con niñas y mujeres
estoy segura el futuro del mundo está en
las mujeres digo somos el 51% de la
población pero también sé que el futuro
del mundo incluso el presente está en la
tecnología tristemente todavía la brecha
de género es
gigante en las profesiones stem que
viene de las siglas en inglés ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas y
recuerden esta palabra porque estaré
diciendo esta palabra durante toda la
charla ted son las profesiones que
lideran el sector tecnológico recordemos
que estas carreras las stem están siendo
necesitadas por la industria tecnológica
que está creciendo a pasos gigantes la
aceleración de la digitalización ha
llegado más rápido que nunca a pasos tan
acelerados que son exponenciales
esto significa que muy pronto las
máquinas superarán a la inteligencia
humana
la llamada singularidad se predice y
llegará para el año 2045 ahora lo vimos
con la pandemia el mundo se volvió
digital de la noche a la mañana
de repente nuevas tecnologías y nuevos
trabajos surgieron pero también muchas
personas los perdieron esto ocurrió
porque no estábamos preparados ni en
educación ni en tecnología para
enfrentar el futuro esto nos sirve para
darnos cuenta que así pasará cuando las
máquinas sean
más poderosas incluso creo que después
de esta pandemia la aceleración hacia la
singularidad será mucho más y más rápida
y no quiero asustarlos pero muchos
trabajos como los conocemos ahora serán
automatizados por máquinas y
desaparecerán de 10 a 20 años como los
empleos administrativos recepcionistas
cocineros bibliotecarios entre muchos
otros
ustedes pensarán que esto tardará pero
esto ya está pasando
si vas al cine por ejemplo podemos ver
que ya hay máquinas vendiendo boletos
incluso ya hay restaurantes y robots que
son totalmente operados perdón que son
los hoteles y los restaurantes son
totalmente operados por robots y me
preguntarán anaka en qué tiene que ver
todo esto con las mujeres pues todo se
viene un futuro donde necesitaremos más
que nunca la ciencia y la tecnología no
quiero ver como el 51% de la población
nos quedemos resaltadas en la famosa
clase de los inadaptados que se dice que
será cuando las personas no se adaptan a
los cambios del futuro y a la tecnología
acaso no lo ven
bueno el futuro está en la tecnología y
si las mujeres no estamos participando
en la tecnología por ende en el futuro
no habrá mujeres y de nuevo tendremos un
mundo que no estará representado por
nosotras en el pasado dejar de lado la
representación de mujeres o de las
minorías en este campo la tecnología ha
traído grandes repercusiones como por
ejemplo cuando una gran empresa de
tecnología empezó a usar el sistema de
reconocimiento facial reconocía más
fácil a los hombres blancos que las
mujeres de color e incluso las
identificaba como delincuentes o al
principio con los asistentes de
inteligencia artificial reconocían más
fácil una voz de un hombre que de una
mujer o cuando crearon la app de salud
de iphone se les olvidó un pequeño
detalle que fue guardar los datos de
salud reproductiva de las mujeres
pero serían problemas banales pero estos
pequeñísimos ejemplos de lo que puede
pasar si dejamos a las niñas y a las
mujeres del lado en el futuro no sólo la
tecnología será exponencial sino también
la falta de diversidad la única manera
que vamos a cerrar la brecha de género
será sin más mujeres y niñas 100
carreras relacionadas con las stem
por eso trabajo para educar a niñas y
mujeres porque creo que la diversidad y
la representación de nosotros en el
futuro depende de lo que enseñamos hoy
pero muy pero por muchos años las niñas
hemos tenido que cumplir ciertos
estereotipos de género y esto nos ha
permitido desarrollarnos no nos ha
permitido perdón desarrollarnos en áreas
que típicamente son para el género
masculino
existe un estudio que se llama la brecha
de los sueños en el que se dice que las
niñas a partir de los 5 años dejamos de
creer que podemos hacer lo que queramos
como astronautas directores de empresas
ingenieras ejecutivas y presidentas por
los estereotipos y nos enfocamos más en
seguir las profesiones que creemos que
sí podemos hacer y si desde niñas nos
dijeron que era mejor que no hiciéramos
cosas difíciles y nos decían ay las
matemáticas son difíciles no sabrás
explorar te vas a ensuciar no uses esta
herramienta deja que tu hermano te ayuda
o no cambies un poco que lo haga tu papá
pues nos están demostrando que las cosas
que requieren un poquito más de esfuerzo
o que son difíciles simplemente no son
para nosotras y aquí está la razón por
la que las niñas cuando crecemos no nos
interesamos tradicionalmente por las
stem
la respuesta es porque nos enseñaron que
cualquier cosa
que
es más difícil y requiere perfección no
es para nosotros no esperamos entonces
que de la noche a la mañana las niñas se
interesaran por las stem porque eso no
va a pasar a menos que les enseñemos a
las niñas menos perfección más agallas
más atrevimiento perseverancia
tolerancia y resiliencia yo por ejemplo
he descubierto que después de haber
trabajado con más de 70 niñas a través
de mi emprendimiento epic wing que las
stem proporcionan los valores de
confianza perseverancia y además que les
dan las las herramientas para animarse a
hacer cosas de verdad difíciles un
ejemplo de esto es con la programación o
la electrónica las programadoras su
programadores no me dejarán mentir que
cuando estamos escribiendo una línea de
código si no ponemos un punto un punto y
coma nuestro programa no va a funcionar
simplemente no funciona
de igual forma pasa con la electrónica
si ponemos un led al revés
en positivo en vez de negativo
simplemente no va a encender ahora
imagínense a una niña haciendo esto a
una niña entre 7 y 12 años intentando
hacer un robot un videojuego o un
programa o un experimento de ciencias
simplemente cuando a una niña no le
salen las cosas la primera vez se le
hace difícil se equivoca o fracasa
quiere dejarlo todo quiere irse por el
camino fácil e incluso que alguien más
le resuelva su problema
pero las stem juegan un papel muy
importante porque las niñas aprenden a
resolver esos problemas de manera
independiente así que al final las stem
les ayudan a recordar los valores que
tanto necesitamos para ser valientes y
pór y por supuesto que ese es el mejor
ejemplo de empoderamiento y para las
mujeres muchas veces seguro nos dijeron
que no éramos buenas para algo o algo
era demasiado difícil
pues no la creímos seamos valientes
comencemos a escribir el futuro que el
mundo necesita porque me gustaría ver un
futuro donde las mujeres sí estén
representadas
dejemos a las niñas hacer cosas hacer
cosas difíciles para cazar intentarlo
muchas veces así desarrollarán mayor
fortaleza y confianza en sí mismas estas
son cuatro acciones que ayudarán a
empoderar a una niña a hacer lo que
quiera uno enseñarle sobre fracaso
aumentar el fracaso nos ayuda a querer
ser menos perfectas y aceptar nuestros
errores y esto crea una mentalidad de
mejorar dos habla de otras mujeres los
modelos de rol a seguir son muy
importantes y mostrarles a otras niñas
ya otras mujeres que están haciendo
cosas increíbles en todas las
profesiones les ayudarán a inspirarse
enséñales una mentalidad de crecimiento
las niñas tienen menos posibilidades en
los niños de asociar su género con las
habilidades intelectuales nunca sugieras
a una niña que puede hacer menos una
actividad y por último evita a toda
costa el perfeccionismo no queremos que
las niñas dejen sus sueños por el qué
dirán
y por no hacer cosas difíciles y bueno
finalmente si estoy segura que el futuro
este ente que en la tecnología pero
estoy más segura que también está en las
niñas
y